[Music]
Chris Pine big news for Wonder Woman
fans today he is back in the sequel
here's the first photo of Chris Pine
seemingly back to the future today on
set in Virginia he's sporting a timeless
fanny pack alongside gal gadot CH for
the sequel now called Wonder Woman 1984
it's clear now his character Steve
Trevor has bounced back from what looked
like a lethal case of midair plane
explosion
but how did the World War one fighter
pilot end up in a Members Only jacket at
the mall and this just released photo
last year director patty Jenkins shot
down the idea of a parachute to ET
could've no parachutes in 1917 I mean
could you have survived the blast I
don't know I guess you'll have to wait
and find out in a second photo released
today
dianna stands in front of screens filled
with mid 80s nostalgia
that's jr. Ewing from Dallas and
Christie Brinkley in the first national
lampoon's vacation movie Kristen Wiig
will also co-star in the sequel she
plays a villainous character called the
cheetah and she's no stranger to 80s
fashion throwbacks from her years on SNL
left it's also widely rumored TV's
Wonder Woman from the 70s Lynda Carter
will make a cameo and that would
definitely need you in Wonju not so good
I talked to her at the time 100 gala
Nancy and she said a patty Jenkins and
gal gadot's want her she's there so I
think it's gonna happen I think so too
[Music]
[Applause]